[Music]
mastering the art of combat requires
preparation and training especially when
leading the two armies of heroes almonds
silica in heroine sometimes armies
require a little assistance so it's best
to brief yourself on the incoming
barrage of downloadable content some
content will be free and some will be
paid but all can be purchased
individually or in packs all five packs
and a season pass that bundles them
together will be available for purchase
on May 19th though some of the content
may be available on other days it all
begins with the fledgling warriors pack
discover items and weapons as you
explore the astral temple encounter
wretches and riches while recovering the
stolen goods of a peddler from brigands
and gather a band of bandages as you
fell wave of terrors the challenge
intensifies in the undaunted heroes pack
dive deep into the inner sanctum
to glean items and weapons from
Sepulchre infested with tomb robbers
choose wealth before help in a deadly
fortress haunted by a spectral army and
gain experience battling unending waves
of vengeful tomb Lords in the Lords of
the grave 10 ancient altars awaits you
in the lost altars pack each allows a
unit to transcend mortal limits giving
way to mighty classes with higher /
class rights such as Spartan Harrier
and Yosh the plot thickens with the
release of the rise of the deliveries
pack you can find out what happened on
the field of battle before the start of
arms taped up and learn character
backstories you may even get to command
units you normally can't control the
time a fifth pack is also on the horizon
stay tuned for more information coming
soon and beginning at launch the goddess
Milla will smile upon you granting you
gifts free of charge steal yourselves
heroes for the true test begins on May
19th